all right so we continue our exclusive
interview with president Trump's
attorney Rudy Giuliani I believe I want
to report to the American people the
truth and when I talked about a rigged
investigation on Hillary and I talked
about the crimes that she committed and
I interviewed you and other great
attorneys and I talked about FISA abuses
and the FISA judge and a two-tiered
justice system and equal justice under
the law have I been wrong at all tell me
I would love to tell you you were right
way back in I don't know whether 2015
when we first started focusing on that
big chart that I made I still have it on
my cell phone I'll bring it up tomorrow
and they're still not investigated no
you're not wrong but Russia collusion
was wrong with Trump Donald Trump
Russian collusion is a total fake news
unfortunately it has become the basis of
the investigation and Muller owes us a
report saying the Russian collusion
means nothing it didn't happen that
means the whole investigation was
totally unnecessary
all the rest of it that came out of it
whether it's the personal thing so the
political things none of it is relevant
meanwhile the man is trying to deal with
North Korea come on the nuclear is like
should of the correct they want me to go
to him and say let's take two weeks off
to get you ready for for a deposition
never should take place in the first
this has gotten personal for those that
are after the president of course it has
yeah of course it's totally personal is
this look at that look at that Holt look
at the whole press corps look at the
color look at the Correspondents Dinner
on Saturday night all right we this was
a short segment we got to take a break
it was horrible okay